i have a hundred thousand dollar
sunglasses on right now because i don't
live in fear
um
there's not much to do uh
at the end here really other than just
wish everyone well i mean the economy is
going to be
so incredibly vicious it is going to
kill you and everyone you know your
families will be on the street they'll
be selling their [ __ ] [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and dicks they'll be doing
everything they can
there's nothing
you'll be plagued by famine by disease
there will be chaos in the streets civil
unrest violence
um authorities uh institutions will lose
all uh credibility very quickly
authority will fall there will be ragtag
group of militias that will be guarding
and distributing resources there will be
regional fiefdoms run by psychopathic
charismatic cult leaders people are
going to feel vulnerable for the first
time in a very long time there is going
to be climate catastrophes and disasters
compounding uh a breakdown of the civil
order there is going to be
probably a
freeze
or shutdown
of local and federal government services
there will be
nowhere to run you're not going to be
able to utilize public transportation
planes trains your automobiles will be
set on fire by bands of angry children
looking for food you are going to be
scavenging
trying to make the most out of what
you've got you'll be eating out of
garbages
okay you'll be living in tents if you're
lucky you'll be walking 10 11 miles a
day from state to state
like a post-apocalyptic film
you will choose friends based on who you
perceive that you could trust at any
given time this is going to change you
will wake up in the middle of the night
and they will be rifling through the
food that you have decided it was going
to last you guys a week
they're going to be stealing water
you're going to have to execute some of
them in front of your own children
you're going to have to keep them in you
have to enforce a certain level of
[ __ ] authority you're going to have
to make people scared and you're going
to have to punish
execute
beat
it's going to be tough
you will not be able to access any
medical care during this time
you're going to be uh you're going to
have to get good at
minor surgeries performing them on
yourself and your children and other
members of your group
you're going to have to perform stitches
stitching your skin together when a
feral rabid animal has taken your arm
and turned it into its chew
toy you may have rabies you may not
you're going to have to get pretty good
at securing medication and drugs and
administering them
uh with your group of people
you know whoever you're traveling around
this country this disaster prone war
zone with trying to acquire resources
you're going to have to be able to
administer
all types of drugs medications novocaine
you're going to have to do minor
surgeries you're going to have to get
and store food you're going to have to
understand refrigeration without a
refrigerator spicing food appropriately
how long things can stay you're going to
be able you're going to make your own
jerky you're going to try meat in the
sun
you're going to have to learn to fish to
grow to live off the grid you're going
to have to become uh familiar with
agriculture farming
storm patterns
irrigation water
you're going to have to do all of that
and while you're doing that
you can listen to jennifer aniston
or jason bateman
so at least you'll still have
entertainment
during this period of darkness
it will be like the noah's ark flood not
everyone will survive
there will be small groups of people
that through their own ingenuity and uh
propensity for cruelty
will be able to get ahead of other
groups
and i don't know which group you'll be
in and i pray for you
but just know that while you are out
there
struggling you will be able to listen
to courtney cox
talk about fun things
that happened on the set
of friends a show that was on in the
1920s when actors could afford to live
in new york city and nobody had aids and
they met one black person
just
know that the american entertainment
system will never fail you
because even though you are going to be
out there
trying to figure out how to set up a
legitimate government once ours has
fallen
when you were trying to get some of the
loose nuclear weapons
that have already been stolen out of the
cheyenne mountain base and many of our
underground military bases
when you and your crew is trying to
acquire weaponry and food
you will be able
to listen
to jason bateman tell you how ozark got
made
because that's what this medium has
always been about
rich
celebrity millionaires
telling you
how cool [ __ ] happened
while you lay on your couch
and pray for death
and that's
the great tradition
of broadcasting
it has always been for rich people who
are bored
who did a cool thing once and want you
to know all about it
while you sit in traffic
and shove another french fry down your
throat
but these my friends are the good times
so enjoy them while you can it's gonna
get a hell of a lot worse
not for me
and not for anyone i know
joe rogan will protect us
he will take us up on a spaceship with
elon musk where we will do stand-up
comedy in a zero-gravity environment for
no one
the rest of you i believe will inherit
earth and fight over resources
until you are exhausted or murdered by a
rival tribe i will be in the sky
with uh elon musk and joe rogan
until i kill myself which will be about
three hours into that experiment
when i decide that i would rather
be having be getting disemboweled by
wild dogs than be on that ship
tim dilloncomedy.com there are no live
dates there's no tour [ __ ] off and go
away
a book's coming i haven't written
i haven't written the book but it's
coming you'll buy it
i hope to get it out before the [ __ ]
war but i don't think i will
but i'm trying
i can follow ben avery but who gives a
[ __ ] for what a picture of a duck what's
he adding to this
go to our patreon if you want extra
episodes or to support the show please
support our sponsors like dick pill and
cigarette uh you can't have a cigarette
so take this
have you lost your hair
hopefully soon we'll get legal services
you want to see your kid again
press two
but please support all of our sponsors
please
it's important for us that you
support the companies that support us
many of these companies
they're not going to see the other end
of this
you know
but that's okay
are you nervous about what's coming or
are you gonna face it head on
no i'm pretty nervous you should be yeah
you should be as nervous as any human
being out there
you should be
nervous
because the podcast producers are going
to be the ones when we tell everybody
the money you've made
they're going to go to your houses with
pitchforks and they're going to drag you
out and they're going to rape you
they're gonna rape you to death
and they should